on va jouer à qui se cache là dessous
c'était ça le principe est simple oui on
va tout de suite envoyé le jingle on va
mettre les trois protagonistes sur
l'estrade pendant le jingle ces partis
qui se cache à tous la td est ce qui se
passe est sous la halle et mais sans
déconner qu'est-ce qu'il a nagée pas dès
maintenant que nos bons challenges
mouche
il faut que faut des boulettes géantes
ouais alors chez mineurs moi je peux pas
alors totale c'est très simple c'est
très simple vous allez regarder l on a
bien une des jupes et à vous de nous
dire ce que vous avez vu pouvait dire la
vérité aux vampires
puis ce sera à mon tour il regardait
d'annoncer ce que j'ai vu d'accord bien
sûr canada qui bluffe vous devrez dire
qu'ils bluffent alors qu'ils doivent ou
non mirek ticket à rompre et lydie la
vérité c'est maximum atemax encore
gardées a brocardé poule à
attention c'est exact alors qu'est-ce
que oui
[Applaudissements]
images vu alors alors il est là la photo
de morandini
jean marc monteil jour majorquin
parcours doudoune jean-marc records
d'audience à des attentats donc là tu
avais une photo de jean marc morandini
ouais ouais voilà et sur rien d'autre
les chiots la question des jetons non
attends yahia une autre chose peut-être
n'ont pas déclenché olala c'est moi je
vois tu reste longtemps du lavage ou
alors ne nous ait pas d'accord ça je
vois un petit écureuil qu une petite
noisette qui dit la vérité la vérité la
vérité cafard record d'audience hier
ferme abbaoui à l'inventer alors nous
verrons ce qui peut pas d'un manque
morandi regarder tout de suite qu'ils
avaient subi la chute du mât tim mcgraw
dont plusieurs y avait les petits sets
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur alors là l'otan prévu cgv tu
vois ce que sap en haïti est ce que tu
vois tu es un petit sapin
un petit sapin apprécié sapin avec les
boulangers goujon a pas de sabra
sentiments les boules
j'ai rêvé de cette séquence depuis sept
ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je vois je vous dis je vois une
merguez avec deux moules est toi qui dit
la vérité totale à chaque talent vous
avez dit quoi vous des petits seins
petits sapins 505 naquit ball mais ça va
bien c'est sympa lequel lourde attention
le troisième alesi shota il est
persévérant brut qu'est ce qui se cache
là dessous
les lots je vois une énorme tab
[Applaudissements]
écoutez fin du game amer tous et leurs
biens qui elle nationaux est à l'arrêt
et retourner à notre place c'est terminé
je vous le dis on n'aura pas mieux